- I want to ask you this,
'cause you've done so much Broadway
that you've forgotten your lyrics.
I've heard that you
kind of did it on stage
and people think it's kind
of a fun thing with you.
- Yeah, no, it's not.
(audience laughs)
It's not a fun thing.
- I'm bad at it.
- It's a nightmare.
- I know I'm bad at it too.
Are you, how are you at it though?
'Cause here's my thing,
somehow I will say something,
it will somehow rhyme.
It won't make sense, but
- So that's what you're taught to do.
What's interesting is I did not do that.
I took the opposite approach
and forgot the human language,
forgot the entirety of
our experience vocally
as a collective species
and just stopped talking
as the music was playing
very loudly, it gets worse.
The stage manager was
screaming the line at me
going you're making things up again.
And all I heard was.
(voice rings)
- What?
- I had like tinnitus or something.
I was a living nightmare.
- Oh, you had a ringing?
- I had a ringing sensation.
- I've had that happen once to me.
- It was like energy up
above got bored that day
and was like, ooh, let's
play with Josh's life.
And it was like, this is insane.
And then my co-star was
screaming the line at me,
and I still couldn't say the line.
I couldn't hear anything.
And then can I curse on your show?
- We'll bleep it.
- You'll bleep it out, good?
This is how I got out of it, okay,
live theater,
people paying $500 a ticket
to see Book of Mormon,
I looked out at my cast and said
what the (bleep)'s my next line?
(audience laughs)
I am a trained professional.
Don't try that at home.
- But you know what, if I'm at that show,
best experience ever.
- But here's the worst
part, they were so confused,
they weren't even enjoying it.
They were just like, this is
a very weird part of this show
right now that's happening.
Does this happen every night?
This script feels like it needs work.
And from that point on, in Book of Mormon,
I actually in the song,
I had an actual Book of Mormon
where I pasted the lines
so that when I opened
it up, I don't care now,
I did it 10 years ago, whatever,
whatever audience you
thought after the fact.
(audience laughs)
- That's clever.
Spoiler alert.
- Spoiler alert.